but what do you want to play a little
amazonite oh yes can I enter like a DJ
capitalism working on something where
he's gonna play Lex Luthor is it you
living in
conscious gratitude writing it down
sharing it with okay well we're still
gonna get together as a family but I
think I just put on my headset and that
song came on and then I just lost my I
adore him I would do anything if he
would help me that would mean something
wouldn't change any of it now because
now I'm on the other side of it and can
look back on
oh you anything and if you're doing a
job what I wanted my son to be like yeah
that's my dad
you know like it was more than just me
who's every do I need a lawyer
oh the court will give you when I went
duck my mother was bipolar you better
believe she like hit you yeah there's
like I was surviving the piranhas of
Hollywood only to find out my brother
was the devil I am NOT my job I am NOT
my success I am NOT my work